Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wir machen heute Salon. Ja. Wir sind angekündigt zu spät.
Ja.
Wir hatten ja gesagt am 18.
Wir hatten aber auch sehr viel zu lesen, nämlich zwei dicke Bücher.
Die liegen hier.
Über Open AI und Sam Oldman und nicht nur Sam Oldman, sondern natürlich auch alles, was da so dranhängt an Ideologie, an Kolonialismus. Bevor wir dazu kommen, wollen wir erst darauf hinweisen, dass wir jetzt am 23. August live zu erleben sind in Frankfurt. Wir werden also einen Live-Podcast auf großer Bühne machen.
Wir packen uns Politiker.
Ich bin gespannt, was du davor hast.
Wir beantworten eure Fragen.
Und ich bringe auch was mit, aber ich will es noch nicht verraten, was ich mitbringe. Jedenfalls gibt es noch Karten.
Das heißt, ich weiß es auch noch nicht.
Der Link steht in der Beschreibung. Jetzt werden natürlich gerade am heutigen Tag viele sagen, wie ordnen Stefan und Wolfgang das geopolitisch und geökonomisch alles ein? Und natürlich müssen wir uns auch zu dieser Sache äußern. Die Rede ist natürlich von Labubus. Ist das für dich ein Phänomen, wo du sagst, da musst du...
Ich weiß nicht, wovon du redest.
Aber komm, du hast schon von Labubus gehört. Das diese kleinen, kleinen Tierchen, die jetzt alle so mit sich führen oder Monster, die alle dabei haben.
Also heute ist der erste Schultag nach Ferien in Hessen. Das heißt, ich bin in ehrenfreudiger Erwartung, was meine Kids heute alles so aus den Ferien der anderen mit nach Hause bringen. Kann durchaus sein, dass ich heute Abend bestens informiert bin.
Und gezwungen ist, so ein Tierchen zu besorgen. Und das wird sehr schwer sein. Ich habe durch einen guten Mittelsmann ein Tierchen bekommen. Und ich habe gedacht, ich lasse es noch verpackt. Ja, das ist das Kistchen. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht genau, was irgendwas zwischen 20 und 30 Euro hat das gekostet. Ich vermute, der Materialwert liegt bei 30.
20 und 30 Euro, das ist doch Happy Meal Zugabe.
Ja, und man weiß ja jetzt noch nicht, was genau drin ist. Man kauft also ein Sechserpaket oder so. Und dann, wir haben schon über diese Karten damals gesprochen, die Sammelkarten. Und hier haben wir ein ähnliches Phänomen. Jetzt ist also die Frage, was verbirgt sich darin? Für die Leute, die jetzt gar nicht im Bilde sind und denken, was reden die da eigentlich? Es gibt diesen Labubu-Trend schon eigentlich eine Weile, aber ich würde sagen, er ist jetzt so gerade auf seinem Höhepunkt angekommen.
Wo kommt der her?
Der kommt aus China. Und zwar gibt es ein Unternehmen, das heißt Popmart. Und dessen Gründer hat sich vorgenommen, so relevant zu werden wie Disney und auf lizenzierte Produkte zu setzen, die man dann in alle Welt verkaufen kann. Und das scheint ziemlich gut zu funktionieren. Und zwar heißt dieser Unternehmer Wang Ning. Dieser hat 2010, also im Alter von 23 Jahren, schon in Peking dieses Unternehmen gegründet. Er hat dann verschiedene Creator engagiert, die solche Tierchen, solche Plüschtiere gestalten. Unter anderem Kasing Lung. Das ist der Künstler aus Hongkong, der diese Labubus kreiert hat.
Aber hier steht gar nicht Labubu drauf. Also wo kommt der Name her?
Also die heißen so, warum das jetzt nicht nochmal extra da drauf steht. Also das heißt jetzt Big Into Energy. Also es gibt immer verschiedene Editionen. Und du kannst dir denken, es gibt Editionen, in denen sich ganz wertvolle Labubus verbergen, die dann für 2.000, 3.000 Dollar gehandelt werden. Und auch jetzt gibt es natürlich einen großen Secondary-Markt, auf dem die Labubus auch die Normalen gehandelt werden. Da ist es sehr schwer, daran zu kommen. Also ich habe jetzt auch zweieinhalb Monate warten müssen. Ich wollte das dann viel früher in diesem Podcast mitbringen. Und dann bekam ich plötzlich von meinem lieben Freund Thomas die Meldung, ja, das wird wohl eher Oktober werden. Und dann rief er mich aber jetzt an, ich weiß nicht, künstliche Verknappung natürlich. Künstliche Verknappung ist ja das eigentliche, worum es da geht. Und dann rief er mich jetzt an, die Labubus sind da. Seine Kinder sind ganz aus dem Häuschen. Und ich natürlich auch. Und jetzt wollen wir einfach mal diese Packung öffnen. Man muss das oben aufmachen. Da ist ja noch kein Kärtchen, glaube ich, drin, hat man mir gesagt. So, jetzt öffnen wir das mal und gucken mal, was wir da bekommen. Ah ja, und dieses Labubu ist dann auch nochmal in einer solchen Tasche. Wir öffnen jetzt die Tasche. Das ist wirklich ein ganz besonderer Moment, glaube ich, jetzt für viele.
Die Tasche nicht kaputt machen dabei.
Und es ist wohl so, dass Eltern in große Nöte kommen, weil sie natürlich diese Dinger nicht herbeigeschafft bekommen. Und was passiert dann? Es gibt natürlich ganz viele Ersatzprodukte jetzt. Die werden aber despektierlich La Fu Fu genannt. Und die chinesische Regierung ist sehr hinterher, die zu Beschlag nahmen. Aber jetzt hier ein Original Labubu. Ist das nicht herrlich?
Das ist sehr herrlich.
Und ich kann es jetzt, wenn ich jetzt wollte, könnte ich das jetzt auch hier mir zum Beispiel an den Gürtel oder an den Schlüsselanhänger machen.
Schlüsselanhänger?
Ja, das tragen ja einige der Spitzensportler jetzt in den USA als Schlüsselanhänger. Und man hat das auch bei Rihanna, bei Cher gesehen, bei vielen K-Pop-Stars. Und das hat ja erst diesen unheimlichen Hype ausgelöst, dass also die ganze Welt nach diesen Produkten schreit.
Okay, gut.
Also das ist auch ein ganz neues Design. Also wir sehen jetzt hier, das ist nicht mehr das übliche Disney-
Das ist der rote, Love.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ich glaube es ist noch irgendwie-
Es gibt Love, hoch.
Gibt es noch ein Kärtchen da drinnen?
Luck, Happiness, Loyalität gibt es auch. Und Secret, das ist nicht Secret, das ist Love.
Also das ist aus The Monsters steht hier nochmal drauf. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob da noch, ach ja, siehst du hier, ist ein Kärtchen. Das ist Big Into Energy und dann Love. Ja, genau, das ist das entsprechende Kärtchen dabei. So und jetzt pass auf, dieses hat ja ein anderes Design als diese Disney Figur. Und viele sagen auch, das ist so hässlich oder so. Gut, ist jetzt sowieso nicht jedermanns Sache, solche Tierchen. Jedenfalls ist doch interessant, dass wir jetzt ein Kulturprodukt haben aus China, das plötzlich einen Hype in der gesamten Welt auslöst, wo vorher nicht schon eine Grundlage gelegt war durch irgendeinen Disney-Film oder so. Also Popmart arbeitet natürlich auch mit Lizensierungen in der Form, dass man jetzt sagt, ja wir versuchen mit westlichen Unternehmen Lizenzprodukte rauszugeben. Aber vor allem geht es darum, eigene Produkte zu machen. Und das ist also hochinteressant, wenn man das mal nachliest, was ich dann getan habe. Inzwischen eröffnet Popmart überall Flagship-Stores, unter anderem auch in den USA. Die Umsätze in den USA sind im ersten Quartal 2025 um 895 Prozent gestiegen, in Deutschland um 600 Prozent gestiegen. Der halbe ist ja so groß, dass die Leute überall campen, um an diese Labubus dran zu kommen. Es gibt auch eine Sonderedition für Coca-Cola und und und. David Beckham hat auch ein Labubu. Jetzt ist aber das interessante, wie der Gründer von Popmart darüber spricht. Also Wang Ning hat in einer chinesischen Zeitung ein Interview gegeben und sagt, unser schnelles Wachstum beruht darauf, dass wir eine offene und integrative IP-Plattform sind, die viele herausragende Künstler und Designer angezogen hat. Wir verwalten diese IPs systematisch. Der Reiz der Kulturindustrie liegt in ihrem Bedarf an starker Softpower, die sich nicht rational berechnen lässt, was bedeutet, dass man ein Labubu nicht einfach mit Geld nachbauen kann. Also der Materialwert hält sich an Grenzen. Aber es geht ja darum, dass man IP hat, dass also diese Urheberrechtliche lizenziert wird.
Ich stelle mich gerade mal von dabei. Disney hat ja das Problem, dass dort gerade die Lizenzen auslaufen bei 70 Jahre und so weiter. Also Mickey Mouse ist ja schon gemeinfrei. Und jetzt kommen wir ja auch in dieses KI-Zeitalter. Das heißt, die ersten Streamings z.B. bieten ja schon an, dass du dir deine Figuren selber zusammenpromptest. Also wie man so ein Business jetzt, nachdem es Disney schon schwerfällt, es zu verteidigen, aufrechtzuerhalten und das jetzt neu zu machen.
Ist gut gedacht. Ich würde aber sagen, gerade weil man heute alles reproduzieren kann, geht es wieder darum, das Zertifikat zu haben. Denn das Labubu hat nun nur Labubu oder hat nur Pop-Mart im Angebot. Ich kann natürlich jetzt beauftragen, genau so ein Tierchen zu machen, aber das ist ja nicht dasselbe. Das stimmt. Und er sagt auch, und jetzt wird es interessant, es gibt ein Sprichwort von der Welt zur Welt. Chinas Kultur in der neuen Ära ist eine Kultur von Weltklasse. Wir schaffen Produkte, die die Menschen lieben und nutzen, um die dahinter stehende Kultur weltweit zu verbreiten. Als chinesische Marke der neuen Generation wollen wir Produkte mit höherer Wertschöpfung herstellen und eine Weltmarke werden. In den mehr als 40 Jahren der Reform und Öffnung haben sich die meisten chinesischen Hersteller auf Effizienz und Kosten konzentriert. Wenn beispielsweise der Preis einer Tasse durch Effizienzsteigerungen in der Produktion von 100 yuan auf 10 yuan gesenkt werden kann, unterstreicht dies die hervorragende Fertigungsqualität in China. Die selbe Tasse kann jedoch mit einem Labubu-Design bedruckt für 100 yuan weiterverkauft werden. Durch die Zusammenarbeit mit Spitzenkünstlern und die Nutzung der ausgereiften Fertigungskapazitäten in China schaffen wir neuen Mehrwert. Das ist meiner Meinung nach Innovation. Innovation ist es vielleicht nicht, aber das Interessante ist tatsächlich, dass man jetzt versucht, Premium-Produkte auf den Markt zu bringen. Das geht natürlich eigentlich nur in diesem Bereich über Lizenzen. Denn die meisten Produkte, wir kennen diese ganzen Figuren, die man von Star Wars und sonst was kaufen kann, sind natürlich in der Herstellung nicht besonders teuer. Aber die Lizenz macht das dann aus, produziert auch dann solche Gewinnmargen. Das ist jetzt also dieser Shift, der stattfindet. Interessant ist ja, dass es tatsächlich glückt. Also dass es international angenommen wird und dass es auch so zu sein scheint, dass natürlich ein paar Influencer auch bezahlt wurden, aber dass viele einfach auf diesen Labubu-Hype ohne Bezahlung aufgesprungen sind. Also ich habe nichts dazu gefunden, dass Rihanna, Cher oder sonst irgendjemand Geld dafür bekommen hat, dass die jetzt auch ein Labubu haben. Das heißt, der Hype ist wirklich viral entstanden und hat sich verbreitet.
Brauchst du halt einen, der es am Ende entzündet? Oder mal anfangen?
Ja, und damit verschiebt sich also sehr viel. Was interessant ist, dass die Washington Post darüber berichtet hat, dass China jetzt sehr hart gegen gefälschte Labubus, also Lafoufous, vorgeht, weil man natürlich jetzt auch ein geopolitisches Interesse hat, beziehungsweise geökonomisches, die chinesischen IPs zu verteidigen, während ja China sonst immer dafür bekannt war, dass dort auch die Louis Vuitton Taschen oder so mal gefälscht produziert werden und die kann man dann für einen Bruchteil der eigentlichen Summe kaufen. Interessant auch, was eine Sprecherin des Außenministeriums namens Mao Ning dazu gesagt hat, die Ästhetik, das Design und die emotionale Resonanz von Produkten wie Labubus trugen dazu bei, dass sich das Land von einem Land, das für Made in China bekannt war, zu einem Land mit chinesischen Marken entwickelte.
Ja, ich bin ja eh gespannt. Ich mache gleich noch mal einen kurzen Abriss des Abbaus amerikanischer Softpower in der Welt. Und das ist ja hier Aufbau amerikanischer Softpower. So albern uns das noch erscheint. Aber in zehn Jahren, wenn diese Entwicklung so weitergeht, werden natürlich chinesische Tom Cruises uns chinesische Flugzeuge erklären.
Also ich glaube, es ist wirklich ein Phänomen, über das man jetzt so viel Kulturkritik schreiben kann. Es gab wahnsinnig viele Artikel natürlich darüber, die sagen, ja, jetzt geben die Leute so viel Geld für irgendeinen Schrott aus und das wird von weit her geschifft. Das kann man natürlich bei fast allen Produkten laufend sagen. Aber viel interessanter ist wirklich diese geopolitische Komponente dabei. Und ich glaube aber auch, dadurch, dass das nicht nur ein Hype unter Kindern ist, sondern unter Erwachsenen, ist das sicherlich auch ein Ausdruck einer Verplüschung der Gesellschaft in der Form, dass man sagt, wir haben diese extreme Härte da draußen, wenn wir an den Krieg in der Ost denken, an den Kriegen der Ukraine und all das. Und zugleich gibt es so den Wunsch, ich will ein Kuscheltier haben, mich auf der Couch zusammenziehen, Decke drüber und ausbänden. Und ich glaube, das steckt auch sehr da drin in diesem Hype, den wir gerade erleben.
Total. Genug des Schabernacks. Jetzt zur Geopolitik oder Geoplüsch.
Ja, wie schätzt du das ein, Trump und Putin das Treffen?
Ich habe nichts verfolgt. Also ich bin ganz blank. Ich habe typischerweise, bevor wir hier Podcast machen, auch wenn ich nichts davon bespreche, höre ich mir noch mal alle aktuellen Heutagenals und Tagesthems und so weiter an. Deutschlandfunk, Tageszusammenfassungen. Nichts davon. Ich war im Phantasialand und habe gesehen, dass Trump, Putin einen roten Teppich ausrollte. Trump zuerst auf den roten Teppich ging, dann gab es Videos, wie gezeigt wurde, wie er rechts und links immer bis an den Rand des Teppichs, weil er es nicht geschafft hat, gerade auszulaufen. Dann hat er, um die Zeit zu überbrücken, eine Verlegenheitsgeste gemacht, indem er applaudierte, als Putin auf ihn zukam. Und dann kam Putin, gab ihm die Hand und streckte sofort den Zeigefinger hoch, im Sinne von, ich mache hier Ansagen, wenn morgen Fotos produziert werden und so, dann ist das mein Zeigefinger. Und ich habe mir gedacht, ja, 10 zu 0 für Putin. Und dann hieß es nur noch, kein Deal, kein Deal, kein Deal.
Naja, dass da so schnell ein Deal bei rumkommt bei einem Treffen, damit habe ich jetzt nicht gerechnet, manche ja offenbar schon. Das wundert mich ein bisschen. So schnell kann das ja eigentlich nicht gehen mit einem Zusammentreffen. Jedenfalls ist es tatsächlich so, dass Putin damit auf dem westlichen diplomatischen Parkett zurück ist. Generell auf dem Weltparkett war er ja immer unterwegs. Das wird ein bisschen ausgeblendet mitunter hier. Aber ja, dass das jetzt nicht die großen Ergebnisse gleich gegeben hat, ist aber erstmal ein Zeichen dafür, dass die Lage sehr instrikat ist, aber ja keineswegs so, dass man jetzt sagen kann, und Trump scheitert da mit dem, was er vorhat, wenn wir überhaupt so sagen können, er hat da was klares vor. Also manche sprechen ja die ganze Zeit jetzt auch in Bezug auf dieses Treffen von Trump und Putin, von Blueprint, Masterplan, von Playbook. Da denke ich immer so, ja, Trumps oder Trump übernimmt das Playbook von oder das ist schon lange der Masterplan der Republikaner. Ich sehe nicht, dass die Trump-Regierungen laufen mit großen Plänen, agiert und diese ausrollt und diese sukzessive verfolgt.
Ja vor allem, da ist jetzt ein halbes Jahr im Abend, man kann sich auch die Statements aus den ersten zwei Monaten anschauen und jetzt Bilanzen ziehen und sagen, alles fail.
Da passt vieles nicht zusammen, sagen wir mal. Also ich finde, dass diese Begriffe ein bisschen inflationär gebraucht werden. Dass du das nicht so jetzt verfolgen konntest, da du im Familienurlaub warst, ist sehr gut. Dadurch konntest du ja auch gar nicht die 87 Männer Podcasts hören, die schon vor dem Treffen darüber spekuliert haben, obwohl man ja nicht spekulieren sollte, wie wohl das Treffen sein könnte. Und ich sag mal so, wir sind glaube ich kurz davor, dass irgendein großes Medienhaus einen neuen Podcast rausbringt, in dem freitags darüber diskutiert wird, wie die Zahlen vom Samstagslautau ausfallen werden. Also das ist wirklich jetzt so eine neue Art von Journalismus-Simulation, dass man immer so sagt, ja wir können, wir wollen ja nicht, aber das könnte auch dies sein und das sein. Und dann zeigt sich nach so einem Treffen, diese ganzen Podcasts kann man auf der Stelle löschen. Das hat überhaupt gar nichts gebracht.
Ja, wenn du die fünf Stunden zu spät hörst, hat die Realität schon wieder alles eingeholt.
Ja, also völlig unsinnig, damit sich zu beschäftigen. Ich habe dann so ein bisschen in Phoenix reingeschaut und man hat natürlich jetzt so eine neue Richtung, wie man über Trump, Putin und auch die Rolle der EU und die Rolle Deutschlands spricht. Die Ukraine wird ja nicht immer so als letztes genannt, was auch doch ganz interessant ist, wie sich das verändert hat zu all diesen Ankündigungen und das entscheidet alleine die Ukraine. Das waren ja immer so Formulierungen. Manche sind aber noch so auf einem ganz harten alten Kurs und ich frage mich, wie geht das so zusammen? Wir hören mal einen ganz kurzen Clip aus einem Phoenix-Gespräch mit Stephanie Barbst, ehemalige NATO-Mitarbeiterin, die da sagt.
Wir als Europäer sind alles andere als zahnlose Tiger. Wir haben in unseren Reihen zwei nukleare bewaffnete Staaten. Wir haben 1,9 Millionen Soldatinnen und Soldaten.
Da frage ich mich dann auch, ja, und was machen wir jetzt mit diesem Tropotenzial?
Ernsthaft zu beginnen, der Ukraine zu helfen, gegen Russland wirklich anzutreten und Russland militärisch in ihrem eigenen Land zu besiegen.
Oh, und dann denke ich mir, ok, also während Trump gerade versucht, dann nach Moskau, versucht, einen, irgendeinen merkwürdigen Frieden herzustellen und man hofft, dass jetzt Europa daran beteiligt wird und das nicht alles über die Köpfe der Ukraine hinweggeschehen, sagt man dann so parallel, also wir würden dann jetzt schon mal Richtung Moskau marschieren mit EU-Truppen, während, historisch eindeutiges Erfolgsrezept, absolut, und hintertreiben damit nicht nur die Pläne von Putin, sondern auch noch die von Trump, der zugleich aber noch unser NATO-Pater ist. Also ich kriege es einfach strategisch nicht zusammen. Also ich bin ja auch bereit, manchmal zu sagen, das ist wohl irgendwie gut gemeint oder so, aber hier weiß ich gar nicht mehr, was das sein soll. Wir erinnern uns alle an diese Sätze, jeder Politiker musste sagen, die Ukraine muss den Krieg gewinnen. So. Davon hört man jetzt fast nichts mehr, weil natürlich auch wir schon sehr früh in diesem Podcast immer wieder sagten, im Bezug auf Mark Milley und andere, dieses Gewinnen wird so nicht möglich sein, zumal ja auch oft gar nicht festgelegt war, was dieses Gewinnen eigentlich meint. Weil manche bedeutete das jetzt tatsächlich Regime Change in Moskau, bei anderen bedeutet das, alte Gebietsansprüche wiederzubekommen oder sonst was. Der Ton ändert sich, aber wie wir das jetzt auch schon bei Corona oder so erlebt haben, bezieht man sich natürlich nicht mehr auf das, was vorher als disqualifizierte Äußerungen oder so hingestellt wurde, sondern jetzt ist das einfach eine neue Wirklichkeit. Wir hören jetzt Friedrich Merz vor einer Woche in den Tagesthemen, er spricht da so.
Wir bereiten uns intensiv auf europäischer Ebene zusammen mit der amerikanischen Regierung auf dieses Treffen vor. Und wir hoffen und gehen davon aus, dass die Regierung der Ukraine, dass Präsident Zelensky an diesem Treffen beteiligt wird. Wir können jedenfalls nicht akzeptieren, dass über die Köpfe der Europäer, über die Köpfe der Ukrainer hinweg über Territorialfragen zwischen Russland und Amerika gesprochen oder gar entschieden wird.
Klingt für mich ein bisschen nach einem Stellvertreterkrieg, was man ja auch lange nicht sagen wollte. Die Ukrainer werden dann immer so als Letztes genannt. Und jetzt hören wir mal hier Friedrich Merz, den Bundeskanzler, was der hier sagt jetzt als nächstes.
Und dann hoffen wir, dass es am Freitag einen Durchbruch gibt, vor allem, dass es endlich einen Waffenstillstand gibt und dass es Friedensverhandlungen in der Ukraine geben kann. Dieser Krieg dauert jetzt seit dreieinhalb Jahren, hat Hunderttausende von Opfern gefordert. Es wird Zeit, dass er zum Ende kommt.
Einfrieren?
Ist das etwa hier Bütze nicht? Oder ist das Friedrich Merz, der doch sagte, wenn ich Kanzler bin, dann aber richtig mit Taurus und so weiter. Man sieht also jetzt neue Wirklichkeit oder man akzeptiert die Wirklichkeit, von der andere schon die ganze Zeit gesprochen haben. Das ist nicht zu gewinnen, das Ding, sagte Mark Milley im November 22. Aber man lässt einfach jetzt noch ein paar hunderttausend Leute sterben. Aber dann sagt man, okay, jetzt müsste man vielleicht doch verhandeln.
Es tauchte einen Text auf, im Freitag oder wo, über linke Podcasts, linke Bro Podcasts, Bubble irgendwie. Wir wurden auch kurz erwähnt. Das war mit einem einzigen Hinweis, dass wir ja auch keine Ahnung von nichts hätten, weil ich mal vor Jahren gesagt habe, dass es ja offenbar in der Ostukraine nichts zu verteidigen gibt, weil die Leute, die dann vor Ort sind, dann doch sehen, ah ja, da fährt man noch mit der Pferdekutsche irgendwie. Und das nennt man Wirtschaft. Und ich habe genau das aber gerade daraus gehört bei Friedrich Merz. Im Grunde ist das Gebiet, um das es geht, nicht ganz so wichtig. Wir haben heute im Salon Literatur zum Thema Demografie und Putins Ansinnen. Da gab es im Krautreporter-Magazin so eine schöne Übersicht einfach, worum es da eigentlich geht. Und ich glaube auch, das wird sich drehen in den nächsten Wochen, Monaten, dass man eigentlich total Abstand davon nimmt, von dem Gebiet zu reden, so wie man jetzt schon nicht mehr von der Panzerschlacht und Raumgewinnen redet, sondern nur noch von Drohne hier, Drohne da und so weiter und so fort. Und alles selbstgenügsam, jeder produziert sich den Kram selber. Also die Ukrainer kaufen sich einfach alles selbst und bauen für 1000 Euro so eine Drohne zusammen. Und so, also es wird, glaube ich schon, so einen Shift in der Diskussion geben. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt. Also Merz jetzt so zu hören von Taurus, hat man lange nichts mehr gehört. Die letzten, die ich noch im Ohr hatte, vom Bundeswehrverband oder wem auch immer, die Rede und Antwort stand im Heuterschanal, war immer, zu Taurus ist alles gesagt. Und dann fragte, ja, ja, li, oder wer auch immer, doch noch mal nach. Nein, zu Taurus ist alles gesagt. Stellen sie mir richtige Fragen und so. Und ja. Ich glaube, dass Schulz vor Jahren sprach davon, dass die Ukraine den Krieg nicht verlieren dürfe und niemals vom Gewinnen sprach.
Das war die richtige Aussage.
Ja, wird sich auch noch als die Aussage herausstellen.
Ja, das war die richtige Aussage. Und das kann man ja alles furchtbar finden. Und es ist auch furchtbar. Nur wir sind ja in dieser Konfrontation. Wir haben die beiden mächtigen, schrecklichen Herren jetzt da gesehen, wie sie sich in Alaska treffen. Dann ist den ja ausgeliefert. Also nicht vollends, aber doch in gewisser Weise. Und ich kann mir natürlich so vieles wünschen. Aber das wird ja trotzdem dann nicht stattfinden. Und es wird eine solche Sache sein. Ich weiß, wie sehr Heusken durch die Mangel genommen wurde, als er sagte, ja, man wird am Ende dazu kommen, dass irgendetwas, wahrscheinlich dem Minsker Abkommen ähnliches, vielleicht etwas besseres verhandelt wird. Und dann hat man gleich gesagt, ja, der wirft die Ukraine nicht in die Frage vor. Das geschieht ja die ganze Zeit jetzt gerade. Und dass die Ukraine gerade in so Aufzählungen, auch bei Friedrich Merz immer so als letztes genannt wird, ist ja nochmal da besonders eindrücklich da zu sehen. Und ob man jetzt weiterkommt mit Trump, indem man da mit allen Leuten hinfährt oder so, das wird man sehen. Es ist jedenfalls in einer, wir sind in einer Situation, wo man nicht jetzt einfach in Schwarz und Weiß, also man kann das gerne für sich selbst so denken, aber das entspricht dann nicht der Realität.
Ja, ich will noch eine Empfehlung, die mir gerade wieder in den Kopf schießt, geben. Denn als ich zuletzt mit Mick darüber sprach im Fernsehpodcast, habe ich darauf hingewiesen, dass die Amerikaner derzeit 200 Atomkraftwerke planen für das ganze KI-Zeug und so. Und auf die Frage hin, wie viele Uran-Aufbreitungsanlagen haben sie denn, ist die Antwort Null. 60-70 Prozent des Zeugs kommt aus Russland und wird auch direkt nach Amerika verschifft. Also da findet allenfalls noch im Papierkrieg so ein bisschen, ne, das haben eigentlich Kanadier gekauft, aber von Inden oder so, aber das Schiff fährt direkt aus Russland nach Amerika. Und die Doku, in der das erklärt wird bei Arte, heißt die Nuklearfalle.
Ich empfehle die auch sehr, ich hab sie mir angesehen, großartig.
Crazy, also wer das gesehen hat, fragt sich bei allen weiteren journalistischen Aufarbeitungen rund um Ronsheimer und so weiter. Wovon die da eigentlich reden? Das hat doch gar nichts damit zu tun.
Ja, ich mein, wie kann das eigentlich sein? Wir haben, ich mein, es gibt jetzt diese Doku, es ist also in der Öffentlichkeit, aber wie kann es sein, wir haben über alle möglichen Sanktionspaketchen gesprochen und da werden noch Louis Vuitton-Taschen nach Moskau geschifft oder nicht, ja, so ein Kram. Und jetzt hat man da...
Das ist eine Nuklearfalle.
Eine Nuklearfalle, ja. Also ich kann auch nur sagen, diese Doku ist auch inöffnend.
Die Amerikaner wollen diese KI-Wende, sie haben die Software, okay. Die Forscher kommen alle aus China oder wo auch immer her, die da im Mittelbau arbeiten. Die seltenen Erden, die man dann in Taiwan verarbeitet, damit irgendwann mal fertige Chips, das ist alles China, Taiwan, das ist die andere Seite der Welt. Die Energie, ja, Amerika hat sehr viel Öl und so weiter, aber das wird nicht reichen, um jetzt diese Wende dazu zu machen.
Sam Altman und Peter Thiel sind die beiden, und das schweißt sie ja besonders zusammen, die sagen, wir müssen an die nukleare Energie denken, die müssen wir ausbauen.
Ja, das ist, also Nuklearfalle, der Titel, selten so gut, hat er gepasst, die Doku muss man da sehen.
Ja, ich will noch einen Punkt machen, Wim Wenders, der Regisseur, ist 80 geworden. Ich bin kein besonderer Fan seiner Filme. Mit über Berlin? Nein, das ist ein wirklich schrecklicher Kitsch. Ja, also ein guter Wim Wenders Film ist Everything Will Be Fine. Oder auch der Film über Pina Bausch, der hat was. Also ich bin, oder Don't Come Knucking, auch ein Film, den man sich ansehen kann. Aber ich finde gerade diese sehr deutschen, überbordend, geschichtsträchtigen Filme sind wirklich hochschwanger und langweilig.
Ja, Wim Wenders als Figur, ich finde ja so als Interviewpartner und so.
Ja, aber ich werde dir jetzt was vorführen, um zu zeigen, ich will hier sagen, das ist so symptomatisch eigentlich für die deutsche Kulturbranche. Und zwar wurde Wim Wenders vor drei, vier Monaten beauftragt, oder dann wurde es veröffentlicht, vom Auswärtigen Amt, ist auch auf dessen YouTube-Kanal zu sehen, einen Film zu machen. Und wir hören jetzt einfach mal rein, Wim Wenders geht also da selbst durch die Szenerie und erzählt.
Es gibt Orte, an denen Geschichte geschrieben wurde, die aber trotzdem kaum jemand kennt. Einer dieser Orte liegt im Herzen Europas, in Raas. Es ist natürlich nicht die berühmte gotische Kathedrale, sondern ein verborgener Ort, der vor 80 Jahren für eine Nacht das Zentrum der Welt war. Eine Schule. Ja, eine ganz normale Schule. Genau hier ist es, auf der Rue Franklin Roosevelt, dass am späten Nachmittag des 6. Mai 1945 ein amerikanisches Armeefahrzeug fuhrfährt, aus dem zwei deutsche Offiziere aussteigen, die sofort in dieses Schulgebäude eskutiert werden.
Wir sind also in den letzten Tagen des Zweiten Weltkrieges und wir ahnen schon, es geht hier um Verhandlungen und der Film ist natürlich nicht nur als Erinnerungsfilm gedacht, sondern will einen Bezug zur Gegenwart herstellen.
Generaloberst Alfred Jodl und sein Adjutant Major Wilhelm Oxenius. Niemand weiß, schon gar nicht die Schüler dieser Schule selbst, dass im Mai 1945 das alliierte Oberkommando hier residiert und General Eisenhower vom Kartenraum dieses Gymnasiums aus die Geschicke der westlichen Alliierten leitet. Unter allen geheimen Räumen Europas war dies der Geheimste, schreibt später ein Zeuge dieser Nacht. Die Deutschen waren gekommen, um eine teilweise Kapitulation nur an der Westfront zu verhandeln. Sie wollten an der Ostfront weiter gegen die sowjetische Armee kämpfen. Aber Eisenhower bestand auf einer Gesamtkapitulation. Schließlich wird spät in der Nacht im Morgengrauen des 7. Mai 1945 um 2 Uhr 41 die bedingungslose Kapitulation von Hitler Deutschland unterschrieben. Sie tritt erst am nächsten Tag am 8. Mai in Kraft. Auf Wunsch der Serviette wird das Dokument auch noch einmal in Berlin unterzeichnet. Die dunkelste Zeit in der Geschichte Europas geht damit zu Ende. Zwölf Jahre Terror, sechs Jahre Krieg, der Holocaust, die schlimmsten Verbrechen, die die Welt je gesehen hat, enden hier in einer Schule im Rass.
Bis dahin alles gut und schön aufbereitet noch einmal. Aber jetzt kommt dieser Sprung in die Gegenwand, der noch etwas irritierend ist.
Seit das Hauptquartier geschlossen wird, gibt der Oberkommandierende die Schlüssel dem Bürgermeister von Rass zurück mit den Worten, dies sind die Schlüssel zur Freiheit der Welt. Der Anblick der Schlüssel hat mich sehr berührt, auch wenn sie heute nur noch Schlüssel in einem kleinen Museum in einem Gymnasium sind und es die Türen, die sie geöffnet haben, längst nicht mehr gibt. Von meiner Kindheit an habe ich 80 Jahre in dem Frieden gelebt, den die Nacht in dieser Schule uns allen gebracht hat. Heute herrscht im vierten Jahr wieder Krieg hier in Europa, es ist auch ein Krieg gegen Europa. 80 Jahre nach der Befreiung unseres Kontinents begreifen wir Europäer wieder, dass Frieden nicht selbstverständlich ist. Es liegt jetzt an uns, die Schlüssel zur Freiheit selbst in die Hand zu nehmen.
Was soll ich jetzt damit machen? Also soll ich jetzt sagen, wir brauchen jetzt die totale Kapitulation Russlands? Also das ist ja die, also ich meine, warum ich das vorführe, ist, dass die deutschen Kulturschaffenden, um diesen schönen Begriff, schönen hübsch hässlichen Begriff mal zu verwenden, eigentlich nur als einzige Referenz, wenn sie irgendetwas außenpolitisch beurteilen müssen, den zweiten Weltkrieg heranziehen. Und ich glaube, dass genau dies dazu führt, dass man unglaublich beklatscht, wenn so Maximalforderungen gestellt werden und da bekommt N. Applebaum einen Preis und Karl Schlögel nochmal einen Preis und danach wieder N. Applebaum und dann vielleicht noch Carlo Massalla. Und dann sind die Schriftsteller auf irgendwelchen Podien, die sagen, wir müssen den Luftraum schließen über der Ukraine und all diese Dinge, weil sie natürlich in diesem Modus sind Kapitulation oder nichts. Und das mag auf den zweiten Weltkrieg zutreffen. Aber diese Analogie, die dann hergestellt wird und die ja hier suggeriert wird, weshalb ja auch dieser Film auf dem YouTube-Kanal des Auswärtigen Amtes erscheint, ist eben eine, die uns intellektuell unterfordert und auch strategisch nicht weiterbringt und auch mit der Realität nichts zu tun hat. Und das finde ich so symptomatisch für die deutsche Kulturbranche, dass sie das eine oder das andere kennt. Und wenn es sich dann doch nicht so eingelöst hat, dann wird man darüber hinweggehen und wird sich auf das nächste draufsetzen. Und dieser Maximalanspruch, du hattest mal irgendwann gesagt, erst hatten wir Siro-Covid, jetzt machen wir Siro-Putin. Das ist etwas, was wir da immer wieder erleben können. Und damit wird man mit Preisen ausgezeichnet und so und ist überall gern gesehen. Ich glaube nur einfach, dass es intellektuell wahnsinnig unredlich ist, das so zu machen. Weil wenn ich daraus eine Schlussfolgerung ziehe, dann muss ich tatsächlich wie Stephanie Barbst von der NATO sagen, wir haben 1,9 Millionen Soldaten, wir haben auch Atommächte, also aufgehen Moskau. Und das kann man nicht wollen. Also man muss akzeptieren, dass man in einer anderen Situation ist, als es am Ende des Zweiten Weltkrieges zum Beispiel war.
Ja, also die Schule war jetzt mehrfach Thema, auch im Heuterschneid vor drei Wochen oder so, als ich das gesehen hatte. Dass er das nochmal sich so aufarbeitet, dass er da auch in eine Vitrine schaut, das ist ja alles noch vor Ort und die Schule ist auch in Betrieb, ist ja eigentlich ganz interessant, dass es so ein lebendiger Ort ist. Dass er in so eine Vitrine schaut, wo dann nochmal die Erinnerungen, so liefen sie damals rein, so spiegelt es das Glas wieder und dann guckt er erschrocken und so. Würde ich alles mal jetzt verbuchen. Wir haben jetzt nur diese drei Minuten gesehen, ich weiß nicht, wie es sonst weitergeht.
Das ist der gesamte Film.
Ah ja, okay. Gut, da würde ich sagen, Vimendas ist hier entschuldigt. Denn der Hinweis darauf, dass es eine Selbstverständlichkeit war, über die man jetzt noch mal näher nachdenken muss, würde ich sagen, stimmt. Aber betrifft relativ wenig die Ukraine, sondern mehr so das deutsch-polnische Verhältnis zum Beispiel. Denn das, was da gerade abläuft, es würde mich nicht wundern und wir kommen ja heute auch, das ist ja in diesem KI-Ding, ist eine Szenerie, also es wird uns grundsätzlich schon mal Ilya Sudskäwer als die eigentliche Masterfigur hingestellt. Und der scheint wohl mit fünf Jahren einfach so einen Augenaufschlag gehabt zu haben, wo es heißt, in seiner Erinnerung war fünf Jahre lang so, keine Ahnung, und dann plötzlich hat er gemerkt, ach so, ich bin's, ich bin ein Mensch, wie auch immer, er ist wie so ein Host in Westworld erwacht. Und Wim Wenders beschreibt das ja auch. 80 Jahre lang hat er sich vor sich hingelebt und es war so Friedensdividende, was wir ja immer hören, und dann plötzlich jetzt, ach so, wir werden dran erinnert, dass nur Ukraine ist, und jetzt sag ich wieder was, was in drei Jahren in irgendwelchen Texten drin steht, ist halt vergossene Milch. Da hat man vorher nicht genug aufgepasst, deswegen ist das jetzt so, wie es ist, und es ist da auch nicht revidierbar oder wie auch immer. Das ist bei Deutschland, Polen anders. Und ich war zum Beispiel selbst als jemand, der der Frankfurt am einen immer höhe, es gibt noch ein zweites Frankfurt. Was ist das für ein Quatsch? Ich würde sagen, diese Region im Osten sollte man sich jetzt nochmal genau anschauen. Unter diesem, Hä, haben wir nicht immer gesagt, da im Osten wählen alle AfD und sie sind zu 50 Prozent eh verloren? Nein, die klären uns gerade darüber auf, wie scheiße ein Alltag ist, wenn ein deutscher Innenminister, um irgendwelche Leute, wo auch immer zu beeindrucken, die nichts damit zu tun haben, sagt, wir machen jetzt an der Ostfront, wir stellen wieder Panzer auf, und dann sagen die Polen aber, wenn ihr das macht, machen wir das auch. Und dann gibt es kurz Verstimmung, und dann ist das aber die neue Normalität. Und dann pendeln plötzlich irgendwelche Menschen in diesem Grenzgebiet hin und her, weil die deutsche Polizei sagt, nee, nicht bei uns, geh mal da rüber. Und dann ist aber da drüben gar nicht die polnische Polizei, sondern so eine Bürgerwehr irgendwie, die sagt, nee, nee, geh mal wieder rüber. Und dann sagen die Deutschen, hä, wieso schickten ihr uns den rüber? Und dann sagen die Polen, nee, das waren nicht wir, das war unsere Bevölkerung. Hier hat man es ja auch mit einem Friedensvertrag zu tun, bei dem alle sicher waren, wenn die Deutschen an diesem geheimsten Ort der Welt, und man weiß gar nicht, wann fand das genau statt, es gab nur danach die Verkündung, wenn die sagen, Deutschland kämpft jetzt nicht mehr, dann atmen alle Deutschen auf und sagen, Gott sei Dank, der Krieg ist vorbei. In Polen oder auch in der Ukraine ist das ja gerade ein bisschen anders. Also wenn angenommen, es käme jetzt zu diesem Heute ist März mit von der Leyen bei Trump und kriegt dann die Verkündung, was er mit Putin besprochen hat. Und es käme dann ganz imaginiert jetzt mal zu einem Friedensvertrag, der beinhaltet, ja, so ein paar Regionen in Russland oder in der Ukraine gehören jetzt Russland oder wie auch immer. Und es wird unterschriftlich besiegelt. Würden sich alle Ukrainer und alle Russen daran halten oder gäbe es da Scharmützel und so weiter, wo dann die Regierungschefs danebenstehen und sagen, sorry, glaub mir, damit habe ich gerade nichts zu tun. Also wären wir schon für Joschyn oder wie er hieß und so, die da alle auf eigene Faust irgendwas machen.
Deshalb ja dieser große Streit um die Sicherheitsgarantien. Wer muss denn da was gerade absichern und aufpassen, dass da nicht wieder was losgeht?
Also es gibt extrem viele Themen, die gerade so zu besprechen sind, wie er das macht. Mit so einem Verweis auf, es kann ganz schön schiefgehen. Nur den Namen Zelensky will ich da gar nicht hören in dieser Diskussion, sondern ich will hören, was macht die polnische Bevölkerung am deutschen Grenzgebiet, die seit drei Jahren in dem Wahlkampf gehört hat, dass die Deutschen wieder die Polen übernehmen wollen und so weiter. Die müsst ihr jetzt selber werden, denn wahrscheinlich kriegen wir schon wieder so eine kolonische urbane Regierung und so weiter. Und dann hilft uns niemand mehr. Ihr müsst es selber machen. So solche Sachen.
Ja, so Gründungen von Bürgerwehren etc., was damit dann hergeht.
Nur, ich sehe hier schon einen großen Auftrag für die sogenannte Kulturschaffenden.
Ich sehe nicht, dass unsere Günster und Intellektuelle das machen, sondern sie springen gerne auf fahrende Züge auf und machen sich dann, sobald sie auf diesem Zug sind, auf nach vorn und werden zum Lokomotivführer und sagen, jetzt aber richtig, jetzt aber Kapitulation, jetzt aber Zero-Covid, jetzt aber dies oder das.
Aber den Appell an meinen Bizeps habe ich jetzt bei Wim Menders nicht rausgehört.
Immerhin noch nicht, aber es hat halt genau dieses Geraune, das dann immer so da ist. Und ich habe es ja jetzt auch gesehen, ich meine Udo Lindenberg, der also offenbar zwischen all dem Eierlikör und so noch mal jetzt gedacht hat, ich muss mich noch mal äußern, sagt dann, dass er jetzt eigentlich immer für Pazifismus war, weil jetzt ging das halt nicht mehr. Und dann denkt man so, ja du im Atlantik-Hotel, du hast doch mit nichts irgendwas zu tun. Was musst du jetzt dich noch mal dazu in dieser Weise äußern? Das ist genau so, dasselbe Niveau wie Heino, der bei Nios erzählt hat, ja ich würde kämpfen. Also ja, ein 86-Jähriger. Also das ist alles so irrsinnig, aber so sinnbildlich für unsere deutsche Kulturlandschaft, dass ich am liebsten, wir reden ja auch gleich so, braucht man ein KI-Moratorium und sowas, ich würde echt gerne mal ein intellektuellen Moratorium haben, dass einfach die deutsche Kulturbranche einfach mal drei Jahre schweigt, versucht mal ein anständiges Buch zu schreiben oder einen guten Film zu machen.
Ja, ich meine, das Moratorium wird ja eh schon vom Publikum veranstaltet. Es lässt sich ja jetzt niemand von Campino oder Ferdienst-Trainer oder sowas.
Aber dass sie noch so permanent medial reproduziert werden, also ist es grauenhaft. Und wenn man nicht mehr weiter weiß, dann wird noch Wolf Biermann oder Hertha Müller interviewt. Es ist alles furchtbar, aber wir wollen uns ja mit den ganz großen Fragen auseinandersetzen und nicht mit diesen Dickeligkeiten aus den deutschen Kulturbetrieben. So stelle ich das Labubu mal weg und greife zu den Büchern. Und zwar haben wir viel gelesen über tausend Seiten. Einmal von Keech Hegge, Sam Altman, Open AI, Künstliche Intelligenz und der Wettlauf um unsere Zukunft. Eine Biografie, die bis in die Kindheitstage von Sam Altman zurückgeht. Und dann haben wir des Weiteren gelesen von Karen Howe, Empire of AI, Dreams and Nightmares in Sam Altman's Open AI. Ein Buch, das nicht nur die Unternehmensgeschichte erzählt und viel über die Intrigen, die dort stattfinden, zwischen Zuzkever, Brockman, Amodei, Altman, sondern es ist auch ein Buch, das sich fragt, haben wir es hier mit einem neuen Kolonialismus zu tun, der sowohl die analoge Welt in Beschlag nimmt, als auch die digitale. Eine Autorin, die sich auch hinaus wagt, die sich ansieht, wie arbeiten eigentlich Clickworker, was haben sie zu tun, wo ist eigentlich hier der große Fortschritt bei denen? Die verdienen dann mal kurz 1,60 Dollar die Stunde, bis dann das auch noch runtergeht auf 90 Cent. Und dann müssen sie sehen, wie sie überleben, während sie den ganzen Tag irgendwelche harten Videos, Bilder sich ansehen müssen, um die KI zu trainieren. Also erschütternd zu lesen. Und dann habe ich noch des Weiteren mitgebracht einen sensationellen Roman, Die Holländerinnen von Dorothee Elmega. Darüber werde ich nachher mehr erzählen. Ich habe dann, weil ich es schon mal vor Monaten angekündigt hatte, endlich das Una-Bomber-Manifest noch einmal gelesen. Und ich bin so erstaunt, diese ganzen rechten Diskurse, alles, was wir jetzt so gerade von Nios, Tishis Einblick, Joe Rogan, Leuten, die da sitzen bei Joe Rogan und irgendwie nochmal sagen, der Leftism ist das Problem, JD Vans, Ulf Poschert, ist alles in dem Manifest schon drin. Es ist wirklich so erstaunlich. Naja, das werde ich besprechen. Außerdem ein Artikel, wer kämpft noch in der Ukraine außer Ukraine, nämlich kolumbianische Söldner. Dann habe ich tatsächlich gesagt, ich gehe mal zu Tishis Einblick. Ich will mal wissen, was denkt eigentlich so dieser reaktionäre Arm des Kapitals über Friedrich Merz? Nichts Gutes. Und ich glaube, da sieht man schon, wie eine klare Brücke zur AfD gebaut wird. Und dann gibt es noch Musik Brahms, Streichquartette.
Sehr gut. Ich rolle mal von hinten auf. Hast du dir schon mal über deine mentale Privatsphäre Gedanken gemacht?
Was kann ich darunter verstehen?
Du hast ja eine innere Stimme, die über Sachen nachdenkt, auch wenn du sie nicht aussprichst. Und die lässt sich anzapfen. Es gibt in den New York Times einen Text über die neuen Studien, wie man die inner voice jetzt schützen kann. Noch braucht man dafür Implantate und so, aber wir wissen ja, in welche Richtung der Fortschritt läuft. Darüber Aufklärung. Außerdem, es ist kein Zufall, dass Russland ukrainische Kinder entführt. Isolde Rudorfer hat noch mal die demografischen Eckdaten des Ukrainikriegs durchgegangen. Weil es im Grunde mein Lieblingsthema ist, Wohnungstausch, die Zeit hat mal eine Bilanz gezogen von einer sehr jungen Autorin, Karlott Pruh, die sich dieses Drama angeschaut hat. Um herzuleiten auf diese zwei KI-Bücher, möchte ich gerne ein Thema kurz beschreiben. Ich habe mir gestern wieder didaktisch überlegt, mach ich es jetzt, der Groschen soll von alleine fallen, während ich darüber rede oder sage ich es ganz explizit und ich habe mich dafür entschieden, es ganz explizit zu sagen. In diesen beiden Büchern wird von Unsummen von Geldern gesprochen. So viel Geld wurde noch nie mobilisiert für nichts, also auch der amerikanische Eisenbahnbau oder was auch immer. So und es gibt aber keine richtige Aufklärung darüber. Vielleicht, weil die Bücher ein bisschen zu früh waren oder so, denn es gibt mittlerweile zwei Podcasts. Wir werden auf beide noch zurückkommen. Einmal von Esra Klein in einem Gespräch und dann im Big Technology Podcast mit einem Professor im Gespräch, bei dem die These aufgestellt wird. Diese KI-Unternehmen bauen KI's als Services, die sie dir pro Monat lizenzieren, damit du sie verwenden darfst, die sich bei 20 oder 200 Euro nicht rentieren, sondern ab 2000 Dollar vielleicht im Monat. 2000 Dollar sind aber schon Einstiegsgehälter für Belegschaften. Was bedeutet die ganze Anstrengung, die da drin steckt, wenn sie aufgeht, rentiert sich im Grunde nur, wenn damit einfach der Arbeitsmarkt ausgetauscht wird. Also Menschen raus, Maschinen rein. Und zwar wirklich im 1 zu 1 Verhältnis. Also nicht mehr so mit ach hier die Assistenz und so weiter und so fort, sondern gibt ja schon diese Idee zu sagen, man schafft es, ein Unternehmen auf 1 Milliarde, also so Unicorn-Niveau zu hebeln, aber nur mit einer Person, die den Rest einfach zusammenbrumpte. Und im Zuge dessen möchte ich jetzt kurz auf den August in Amerika eingehen, denn es gab von Donald Trump am 4. August eine Siegeserklärung auf Truth Social zum Thema Promise made, Promises kept, negative net migration for the first time in 50 years. Also das erste Mal hat Amerika eine negative, also eine Auswanderungsbilanz vorzuweisen, die dann in einer Pressemitteilung des Weißen Hauses auch nochmal abgefeiert wurde, mit Verweis auf According to CNN. Also man kommt gleich auf die Quellen, die man sonst nicht so mag, die jetzt Trump beglückwünschen dafür, eine negative Migrationsbilanz vorzuweisen. Und ich will mal kurz umreißen, was das bedeutet. Also Amerika hatte als John F. Kennedy die Mondrede hielt, also die Ankündigung, wir fliegen innerhalb eines Jahrzehnts auf den Mond. 186 Millionen Einwohner. Wir sind also hier nicht wie in Deutschland. Man kommt aus dem Krieg und eigentlich strömen alle zurück und so weiter. Es gibt so Flüchtlingsmigration und wir waren damals 75 Millionen, die Leute sind mal 80, so. Sondern nein, Amerika war damals zu JFKs Zeiten 186 und als die tatsächlich auf dem Mond gelandet sind, waren es schon 202 Millionen. Und zwar grundsätzlich sogar 203 Millionen. Also innerhalb von sieben Jahren ist Amerika von 186 Millionen auf 202 Millionen gewachsen. Heute, 2025, 342 Millionen. Also alle demografischen Ideen von Putin mit vor 100 Jahren hieß es, das große russische Reich, 150 Millionen wird 500 Millionen Einwohner haben und heute sind es 134 Millionen. In Amerika ist das die Realität. Ja. Sie haben sich verdoppelt, seit sie auf den Mond geflogen sind und JFK diese Ansage machte. Und es gab dazu auch ein Immigration and Nationality Act of 1965, der nämlich sagte, ab jetzt keine quotenbasierte Einwanderung mehr, sondern die Welt ist willkommen. Jeder, der möchte, darf kommen und Kinder, die hier geboren werden, sind automatisch Amerikaner. Alles das, was Trump jetzt sozusagen nicht möchte. Außerdem, mit der Migration hat sich natürlich Amerika weltweit auch als Softpower und Hoffnungsland etabliert. Also es gab die Flüchtlingsströme Brain Drain aus dem Osten, Ungarn, Vietnam, Kuba. Jedes Mal, wenn da irgendwas los war, strömten die Leute nach Amerika, weil sie wussten, da ist es safe. Oder das ist das Land, das uns ultimativ beschützt. Also warum hier auf Kuba irgendwie hoffen, sondern dann einfach wissen, in New York werden wir auf jeden Fall beschützt. Und damit hat man sich natürlich diese wirtschaftliche Dominanz geschaffen, weil man zum einen, und das ist ja heute auch wieder, wer flüchtet, derjenige, der es kann und sich was davon verspricht. Also man kriegt schon so die Besten der Besten. Also da ist so eine gewisse Auswahl drunter. Plus die verankern ja dann wieder mit Familien in der Welt Amerika als, ich erkläre euch mal, wie die Welt funktioniert, indem ich euch von Amerika erzähle, überall in der Welt. Also diese ganze Soft-Power-Etablierung. Dann allerdings Corona-Tief. Amerika hatte 2021 nur noch 674.000 Einwanderer. Was bedeutet, die Bevölkerung wuchs nur um 0,16 Prozent. Historisch niedrig. Dann allerdings nicht Trump, sondern Joe Biden. Was hieß große Investitionsoffensiven. Bitte bringt euer Geld hierher, kommt gleich mit und so. 1,3 Millionen Einwanderer. 2024, da kann man dann auch mal sehen, welche Bauchlandung Amerika gerade hinlegt. 2,8 Millionen Einwanderer. Höchstwert. Und jetzt 2025 netto negativ. Also das kann man sich einfach gar nicht vorstellen, was da gerade in Bewegung ist und so. Und jetzt zu den ökonomischen Zahlen. Dann ist die Frage, was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn diese Art von Migration auf die Amerika seit 50, 60 Jahren immer selbst einfach abbricht? Es gibt eine Prognose des Congressional Budget Office. Also das ist sozusagen bipartisan. Der Kongress selbst hat da seine Beiräte. Die Prognose 2024 auf dieser Basis von 2,8 Millionen Einwanderungen oder Nettowachstum, also es war Brutto noch viel mehr Einwanderungen, Nettowachstum 2,8 Millionen, war, dass Amerika innerhalb der nächsten zehn Jahre, also von 2024 bis 34, um 8,9 Billionen Dollar wächst. Das ist zweimal Deutschland, zweimal die drittgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt, weil Wachstumsprognose für das nächste Jahrzehnt in Amerika eingeplant. Und jetzt sagt Trump einfach, ne, ist nicht. Also schneide diese Entwicklung einfach ab. Goldman Sachs und so alle riesige Analysen dazu. Es gibt jetzt Studien zum Thema Warnung, Prognose, was heißt eigentlich Donald Trump im Oval Office. Es könnte sein 2025, dass Amerika 525.000 Menschen in der Bevölkerung verliert, was sich äquivalent laut American Enterprise Institute auf bis zu 0,4 Prozent auswirkt. Und das ist sozusagen der Initiale. Danach verstetigt sich diese Entwicklung und hat so eine eigene Eigendynamik. Alle warnen, die Federal Reserve Bank aus Dallas, das ist also Texas, hat eine der schlimmsten Warnungen ausgesprochen, also Economic Policy Institute warnen vor, also warnen einfach davor, dass man jetzt 1 bis 2 Millionen Menschen durch Eis einfach abschiebt. Plus darauf kommt ja noch diejenigen, die man dadurch vergrämt, die also gar nicht überlegen, da hinzuziehen oder sich dann von dort auf den Weg machen. Also es sind wirklich schlimme, schlimme, schlimme Zahlen. Man reagiert ein bisschen darauf hier in Europa. Also es gibt von Macron so ein Anwerbeprojekt, wo irgendwie 100 bis 500 Millionen Euro bereitgestellt werden. Von allein ist da auch mit eingestiegen. Es gibt auch deutsche Programme, 1000 Köpfe plus Programme, also dass man so einen Brain Drain aus Amerika jetzt holt. Und am verrücktesten fand ich folgende Zahlen. Ich hab mir mal, da es ja nicht nur diese Migrationswelle gibt, sondern auch noch den Kampf gegen die Intelligenz in den Universitäten und so. Also, Harvard hat eine oder alle Universitäten haben einen Anteil ausländischer Lehrkräfte von 22 Prozent, in Harvard sind es 43 oder irgendwie so in diesem Maßstab. Kennziffern, promovierte Wissenschaftler, der Computer- und Mathematikwissenschaftler sind zu 58 Prozent nicht in Amerika geboren, sondern das ist importierte Kompetenz. Ingenieure, 56 Prozent. Alle Wissenschaftler und Ingenieure mit Doktortitel in den USA sind zu 43 Prozent nicht dort geboren. Also das sind diese, in den letzten 60 Jahren kamen sie einfach. So, das ist das Alter, in dem man nach Amerika zieht. MINT-Arbeitskräfte, 29 Prozent kommen von den Ausländern, sind aus Indien, 11 aus China. China hatte ja im Ressourcenstreit um die seltenen Erden und so weiter, Handelsstreit, Zölle und so, war der Zugang zu amerikanischen Unis Platz 1 auf der Forderungsliste Chinas, weil sie einfach wissen, die gehen dahin, kommen dann wieder zurück. Und bislang hat man in China noch nicht dieses offene, wir sind die Forschungseinrichtung der Welt, bei uns kann man einfach frei forschen und so, sondern nein, da läuft ja alles unter chinesischer Bürokratie, in Anführungszeichen, also da hält der Staat so die Hand drauf. Weshalb man sagt, okay, für diesen kurzen Moment der Ausbildung gehen alle nach Amerika und kommen dann nach China zurück. Die Inder sind bislang einfach alle geblieben. Also die sind einfach rüber und haben dann gesehen, ah ja, hier ist ja viel cooler als zu Hause, also bleibe ich. Jetzt bietet sich aber diese Möglichkeit gar nicht mehr, denn die Ansage an Harvard ist ja derzeit keine ausländischen Studierenden.
Ja, ich sag mal, wenn China und Indien von ihrem autoritären Gehabe etwas wegkämen und mehr freie Forschung ermöglichen würden, also wirklich zu sagen, hier kann freige Forschenden machen, was er will, was glaubst du, was das Leute anziehen würde und wie problematisch die Situation dann erst für die US-Unis würde?
Ja, also das chinesische Silicon Valley heißt Wuhan. Wir kennen es natürlich jetzt nur wegen diesem Virus und so, aber in Wuhan gibt es 4000 Unternehmen, die als Erfolgsversprechen für diese 50-Schlüssel-Technologien und so gelten. Und die Leute leiden dort unter Bürokratie. Also die kommen da hin und wissen einfach, oh nee, jetzt muss ich mich hier ewig und so weiter. Wir lesen das ja in dem KI-Buch auch, dass sie so Meta, ist ja, willst du uns in Meta verwandeln? Das ist so das Schimpfwort für Bürokratie. Wie es bei Google aussieht, wissen wir. Die waren ja auch davor, wo wenn GPT-4 zu klug wird, wecken wir Google. Dann vergessen die nämlich ihre Bürokratie und werfen da alles rein und so. Also Bürokratie ist hier ein echtes Problem. Und in China ganz besonders. Das heißt, in China, die haben zwar auch demografische Probleme, aber die können halt noch Demografie abbauen und damit Potenziale entfesseln, die in Amerika schon entfesselt sind. Aber jetzt wird in Amerika eben die ganze Infrastruktur einfach abgebaut.
Der Wunsch der Republikaner ist ja, dass jetzt echte Amerikaner, Anführungszeichen, mehr Kinder bekommen.
Genau.
Was ja nicht passiert.
So, das passiert nicht. Also 1,6 Kinder pro Frau, historisches Tief auch in Amerika. Was bedeutet, Amerika verspielt gerade 8,9 Billionen Dollar BIP-Wachstum in den nächsten zehn Jahren. Und meine Vermutung ist, irgendwer hat den Floh ins Ohr gesetzt, dass die KI das ausgleicht. Und deswegen sind die Investitionen so hoch. Man muss sich das vorstellen.
Und die sitzen ja einem Problem auf, ich werde das nachher erläutern, weil das ja nicht sein kann. Also hier müssen wir jetzt zurück zu Marx, denn das geht nicht. Also das BIP kann nicht gesteigert werden ohne Arbeitskräfte auf Dauer.
Also ja, das ist ein neues Paradigma, dass die Maschine so mitdenkt und eigene Entscheidungen treffen kann. Aber am Ende braucht, und es ist ja auch so eine Marktslosung, du brauchst auch Konsumenten.
Zum Beispiel.
Es reicht nicht, nur Sachen herzustellen.
Der Wert entsteht durch Arbeiter. Das wird immer so ausgekann-
Arbeit und Verbrauch. Also der Mensch macht halt so Sachen.
Und zu glauben, man kann das alles so machen, deswegen denken die auch alle, das werden wir auch bei Sam Altman noch mal hören, an bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen, die Maschinen erwirtschaften ist. Mit irgendeiner Steuer ziehen wir dann Geld ab und das zahlen wir allen aus. Das ist eine Nonsensökonomie. Das funktioniert überhaupt nicht. Und das jetzt nicht, weil ich generell skeptisch gegenüber dem Bürgergeld, gegen bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen bin, sondern das kann nicht gehen. Und das müssen wir gleich nochmal herausarbeiten. Und ich glaube aber auch, diesen Flow hat man denen ins Ohr gesetzt.
Ja, die glauben daran. Also man muss sich vor allen Dingen kennenlernen.
Du sagst jetzt schon zweimal Glauben. Und ich hab's auch schon gesagt, wir haben es hier mit zwei Büchern zu tun, die erzählen uns eigentlich was von der Religion. Also wir lesen jetzt gleich zwei Bücher über Religion.
Und zwar die indische. Das sind alles diese braven Hinduisten.
Es ist eine neue Religion, die sich hier herausgebildet hat, die offenbar sehr wirkmächtig ist und auch ökonomische Rationalität einfach beiseite schiebt, wenn es mit dem Glauben nicht zusammen geht.
Also ich habe jetzt die Zahlen nur bei Scott Galloway gehört, weil er sie wiederholt hatte, aber sie scheint zu stimmen. In Amerika überragen dieses Jahr die Investments in KI das komplette Consumer Spending. Also alle Privatausgaben werden gerade in den Schatten gestellt davon. Und finde ich interessant, dass es überhaupt geht so. Also dass der Mensch nicht mehr das Zentrum der Wirtschaft ist, sondern jetzt einfach so eine Idee, die parallel gebaut wird. Und ich will nochmal darauf hinweisen, ich habe einfach nur gefordert in meiner Kinderwüste, dass wir das deutsche BIP von 4 auf 5 Billionen vergrößern und eine den Familien geben. Es geht also offenbar, einfach die Consumer-Seite zu nehmen und zu sagen, wir bauen mal was Größeres daneben. Das könnte man also, da die Amerikaner jetzt voll in, wir investieren in Maschine, vielleicht wäre es eine deutsche Idee sozusagen, wir gehen in die Menschen, wir investieren jetzt in Menschen. Wir bauen jetzt keine Datensimter irgendwohin, sondern einfach in die Schule. Und dann gucken wir mal in zehn Jahren, wie sich das rechnet im Systemstreit Europa gegen Amerika. Weil ich glaube, das geht nicht auf.
Ja, und da jetzt versuchen mitzustinken, funktioniert eh nicht. Und das wird nicht aufgehen. Also ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt gleich mal diese Religion religionskritisch unterziehen. Also hier ist wirklich Ideologie-Kritik gefragt worden. Im Sinne von, was meinen eigentlich die Katholiken damit, warum sollen jetzt Homosexuelle so behandelt werden? Und warum kein Sex von der Ehe? Und warum sind Frauen so und so? Und das haben wir alles erarbeitet uns, dass wir das kritisch betrachten und dass wir da quasi in der Moderne angekommen sind und schrittweise auch der Katholizismus dann dazu bereit war. Das machen wir mit anderen Religionen auch mehr oder weniger. Und jetzt hier haben wir es mit einer neuen Religion zu tun. Die müssen wir jetzt auch schon mal gleich wie in Mendenakratik unterziehen. Und das geht vor allem über die Ökonomie. Und dann kann man sagen, ja, das sind komische Fantastereien. Und da hinzu kommt noch dieses eigenartige Verständnis von Intelligenz und Bewusstsein, was man diesen Maschinen zuschreibt. Merkwürdig, also es haben gerade sehr viele Leute, die merkwürdiges Denken sehr viel macht.
Prinzip Hoffnung, das ist ja das grüne Luludens.
Ja, also das Labubu, Stefan und ich gehen jetzt in den Salon. Und wir sprechen über die genannten Bücher jetzt erstmal ganz ausführlich über OpenAI.
Ich habe 60 Seiten Notizen mit sehr vielen Pointen.
Ach du lieber Gott. Ja, also ich habe etwas weniger Notizen, aber auch ein paar Pointen. Wer das hören will, kann unseren Podcast einfach über Steady, Patreon oder Apple abonnieren. Das ist so, das ist der Paywall-Inhalt. Manche werden jetzt sagen, aber das habt ihr doch schon so oft erzählt. Ja, aber manche wissen es immer noch nicht. Ich bekam jetzt auch von einem Journalisten einen Anruf, der mich fragte, was macht ihr da eigentlich und so. Ja, wir sprechen in diesem Salon über Bücher, die wir gelesen haben und verhandeln daran die aktuellen Themen. Und außerdem gibt es dann noch Empfehlungen von uns, Lektüreempfehlungen, die wir aus dem Monat mitgenommen haben. Jetzt aber erst mal werden wir zwei Stunden über diese beiden dicken Bücher zu Altman und dem ganzen AI-Kram besprechen. Das ist die einzige Möglichkeit, den Podcast zu unterstützen. Und wir freuen uns, wenn ihr das tut. Stefan erklärt jetzt noch ganz kurz, wie man das denn macht. Wie kommt man in diesen Salon hinein, wenn man doch bislang nur dem Podcast freigehört hat?
Also ihr geht zu GPT 5 und fragt, wie komme ich in den Salon? Ihr geht auf neuezwanziger.de und da ist ein goldener Button mit dem Salon. Da klickt ihr drauf, dann kommt ihr zu Steady, unsere bevorzugte, präferierte Zahlungsmethode. Denn dort ist einfach das ganze Archiv. Da bleiben also keine Fragen offen. Da gibt es immer das aktuelle Coverbild, alle Kapitelmarken. Ihr kriegt ein RSS-Feed. Ihr könnt das in der Podcast-App eurer Wahl hören. Außer ihr seid schon Apple-Fanboys. Dann könnt ihr einfach im regulären Feed auf, die Folge gibt es auch, bezahle ich, kostet dann einen Euro mehr. Oder wenn ihr schon einen Patreon-Account habt, da gibt es auch einfach den Salon zu buchen. Aber wenn ihr neu in diesem Paywall-Ding seid, dann geht es zu Steady.
Und wenn ihr bei Steady seid, wir würden uns auch freuen, wenn ihr ein Jahresabobuch abschließt. Also ihr könntet das monatsweise buchen. Kein Problem. Besser ist es, wenn ihr ein Jahresabobuch abschließt. Erstmal ist es etwas günstiger. Und es ist auch besser für uns, denn wir haben gesehen, diese ganzen Zahlungsdienstleister nehmen von...
Die passieren jedes Mal mit, wenn eine Zahlung ausglückt.
Ja, und von Monat zu Monat mehr. Also es ist wirklich obskur. Und da hängt natürlich auch am Ende hier, der oft erwähnte in den Büchern, Peter Thiel dahinter.
Ja, und Borgman, der hat ja bei Stripe gearbeitet.
Stripe, PayPal, also diese ganze Geschichte, alles geht da immer noch so mit. Insofern ein Jahresabobuch vermeidet zumindest, dass sie jedes Mal noch mal Zugriff haben und gibt uns auch ein bisschen Kontinuität. Wir freuen uns, wenn wir uns gleich im Salon wiedersehen. Bis dahin.
Bis gleich.